[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen die zwei
staatenlösung als Weg zufrieden im Nahen
Osten existiert schon länger nur noch
als schöner Traum und in den
Sonntagsreden von Politikern die
Realität sind neue Anschläge gestern auf
Gläubige vor einer Synagoge in einer
Siedlung im Osten von Jerusalem sieben
Tote heute in der Nähe von Jerusalems
Altstadt zwei Verletzte die Realität ist
neuer Angst vor palästinensischem Terror
Realität ist auch eine frisch ins Amt
gewählte Regierung in Israel deren
Polizeiminister als politischer
Brandstifter gilt der bereits wegen
rassistischer Hetze verurteilt wurde die
Sorge steigt dass die Lage eskaliert
Michael Beverungen mit mehr
was Gewalt und Terror mit Menschen
machen das kann man gerade in Jerusalem
beobachten Shimon Israel zeigt uns ein
Einschussloch in seinem
Wohnzimmerfenster er wohnt gegenüber der
Synagoge vor der gestern ein
palästinensischer Attentäter sieben
Menschen ermordete er wollte auf mich
schießen da bin ich ab nach Hause also
hat er ins Fenster geschossen verstehst
du er wollte mich umbringen
Simon Israel bekennt sich selbst offen
zu einer verbotenen religiös
rechtsextremen Terrorgruppe der
kachbewegung das Attentat hat seinen
Hass auf alle Palästinenser noch stärker
gemacht die Regierung muss ganz klar
sein niedermail und ganz Jenny
verbrennen keine Soldaten mit
Flammenwerfern von oben was sie hier
machen vergelten wir Ihnen dort jeden
Tag 3000 Beerdigungen nur so verstehen
sie es
das blutigste Attentat seit über 10
Jahren verstört Israel und dass die
Brutalität und Entschlossenheit des
Täters auf den Straßen von Gaza gefeiert
wird die Hamas bekennt sich zu dem
Anschlag als Rache für eine israelische
Militäraktion in Genie bei der am
Donnerstag 8 palästinensische Kämpfer
und eine Zivilistin getötet wurden
Vergeltung als Rechtfertigung für
wahllosen Terror
[Applaus]
wenn es Kriege zwischen Armeen gibt ist
das eine Sache aber am Abend des
Schabbat an dem Menschen für den Frieden
beten dazu kommen und sieben Menschen zu
ermorden das ist einfach schrecklich
noch verstörender vielleicht wenn Kinder
zu Attentätern gemacht werden wenn ein
13-Jähriger seine Waffe durchlädt und
jüdische Passanten nieder schießt wie
heute morgen in Jerusalem zum Glück nur
verletzte aber Israels rechtsextremer
Sicherheitsminister übrigens ein
verurteilter Unterstützer der
kachbewegung fordert jetzt mehr Härte
bestimmte aus seiner Sicht illegale
Bauten von Palästinensern in Ost
Jerusalem wieder sofort einreißen lassen
sowie eine Nationalgarde im Inneren
aufbauen und
als erstes müssen wir die Todesstrafe
für Terroristen beschließen
premier Natanja kündigte an Terrorismus
Unterstützer sollten ihre
Sozialversicherung verlieren dazu
weitere Schritte
diese beinhalten die deutlich
beschleunigte Ausgabe von waffenscheinen
an autorisierte Zivilisten wie wir immer
wieder gesehen haben rettet das Leben
aber auch so reagieren Menschen in
Israel auf die Gewalt 10.000 die
wöchentlich gegen die Regierung
demonstrieren gedachten am Abend mit
einer Schweigeminute ihrer Toten
unser nächstes Thema heute Abend unsere
Nachbarn in Tschechien haben einen
General zum Präsidenten gewählt das
klingt auf den ersten Blick alarmierend
aber nur auf den flüchtigen ersten Petra
Pavel war bis 2018 als erster general
aus einem ehemaligen Warschauer Pakt
statt Vorsitzender des NATO
militärausschusses er hat sich heute in
der Stichwahl deutlich gegen André
Babisch durchgesetzt der mal
Ministerpräsident war und einen
Wahlkampf mit heftigen Attacken geführt
hatte auf der Prager Burg zieht jetzt
einer ein der Kooperation Anständigkeit
und normale Kommunikation verspricht was
so sagt er in den letzten Jahren sehr
gefehlt habe
gehen wir zu Britta Hilpert guten Abend
Britta live in Prag der tschechische
Präsident hat repräsentative Aufgaben
aber er ernennt auch Regierung und
Verfassungsrichter und ist
Oberbefehlshaber der Armee was hat denn
Europa jetzt vom neuen von Pavel zu
erwarten
vom neuen hat Europa das
zuerst der NATO kennt
verlässliche und skandalfreiheit
Zusammenarbeit und damit ist er schon
mal ein großes Kontrastprogramm zum
ehemaligen Ministerpräsidenten und
Militär Milliardär andre barbestellen
Europa vor allen Dingen Provokation und
Populismus auf viel und so führte
bayerisch eben auch seinen Wahlkampf
erbisch Stunde für den Frieden und der
generalpaar will der wolle ja die Nation
nur in den Krieg führen das war die Art
von Desinformation die ihm ein großer
Teil der Menschen hier nicht abgenommen
hat der Wahlkampf verschmutzt sich
gipfelte dann auch noch in Todesmeldung
das Kandidaten Pavel aber selbst da
zeigte er schon dass er stressresistent
ist reagierte mit selbst ihre nie mit
einem Stan alive Video richtig ernst
wurde die Sache aber als Babel im Rahmen
barbisch im Rahmen seines Friedens
seiner friedenskampagne sag ich mal sich
sogar dazu versteckt die NATO Bündnis
Treue in Frage zu stellen das sorgte für
Kopfschütteln natürlich in den
europäischen Hauptstädten und ich glaube
das hat ihm auch zu Hause Stimmen
gekostet auch das Pavel jetzt so
überzeugend gewonnen hat dass so schnell
die Gratulationen aus den verschiedenen
Hauptstädten des Westens uns auch aus
der Ukraine hier in Prag eintreffen das
zeigt so denke ich dass dieser Sieg von
Pavel mit einem gewissen aufatmen zur
Kenntnis genommen wurde sagt life aus
Prag Britta Hilpert Britta vielen Dank
und weitere wichtige Nachrichten jetzt
an diesem Samstag haben wir ne Heinz
Samstag bitte du im Osten der Ukraine
gibt es weiter schwere Gefechte das
russische und das ukrainische Militär
melden Angriffe nach ukrainischen
Angaben wurden bei einem russischen
Angriff auf ein Wohngebiet in der Stadt
cosiantinifka mindestens drei Menschen
getötet und besonders massiv hätten die
russischen Truppen auch
und bachmut beschossen
der Ukraine Krieg und dessen Folgen sind
auch Thema bei der ersten
Südamerika-Reise von Bundeskanzler
Scholz zu der er am Morgen aufgebrochen
ist Ziel seiner Besuche in Argentinien
Chile und Brasilien ist eine engere
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit sind den
Bereichen Energie-
der frühere Verfassungsschutzpräsident
Hans-Georg Maaßen der jüngst wegen
umstrittener Äußerungen zum Austritt aus
der CDU aufgefordert wurde ist neuer
Vorsitzender der Werte und Union wie die
Gruppierung mitteilte wurde Maßen auf
einer Mitgliederversammlung mit 95% der
Stimmen gewählt die werteunion die sich
selbst als konservative Basisbewegung
bezeichnet ist kein offizieller Teil von
CDU und CSU
in den USA hat ein weiterer Fall von
Polizeigewalt Empörung und Proteste
ausgelöst ein 29-jähriger schwarzer war
wenige Tage nach einem Polizeieinsatz im
Krankenhaus gestorben jetzt wurden
Videoaufnahmen von dem Vorfall im
Memphis veröffentlicht die zeigen wie
mehrere Einsatzkräfte ebenfalls schwarze
auf den Mann einschlagen nachdem er
zuvor in seinem Auto angehalten worden
war fünf Beteiligte Polizisten wurden
inzwischen aus dem Dienst entlassen und
angeklagt in mehreren Städten gab es
Demonstrationen gegen Polizeigewalt und
für Reformen
die reinen Zahlen sind schon unfassbar
zwei Milliarden einzelne Passagier
Reisen erwarten Sie in China jetzt in
den 40 Tagen rund um das Neujahrsfest es
sind rührende Szenen Familien die wegen
der drastischen corona-maßnahmen seit
Jahren getrennt waren sehen sich wieder
Eltern und Kinder fallen sich in die
Arme endlich wieder zusammen aber die
Angst ist auch dabei denn eine andere
Zahl ist ebenso unfassbar experten
rechnen bis Ende April mit bis zu 1,7
Millionen Corona Toten unter einer
völlig unvorbereiteten Landbevölkerung
offiziell zählt keiner mehr mit darf
keiner mehr zählen unsere
china-korrespondentin Elisabeth Schmidt
hat sich auf eine düstere Spurensuche
gemacht
jeder dieser Erdhügel ist ein Grab wir
sind in der Provinz Röbel unterwegs gut
100 Kilometer südlich von Peking finden
wir Belege dafür dass die kurvezahlen in
China weit höher sein müssen als die
Behörden angeben zahlreiche Gräber sind
mit Blumen geschmückt diese Landarbeiter
bestätigen uns dass es neue Gräber sind
wir fragen ob die Menschen an Corona
gestorben sind ja ankovic
es sind viel mehr Leute gestorben als
sonst erfahren wir sogar aus Peking
haben sie ihre Toten hierher gebracht
weil sie in den Krematorien dort so
lange warten mussten
auf den Feldwegen finden wir auch
zahlreiche Blumen Baldachine sie werden
über Särge gehalten wenn die Toten zu
Grabe getragen werden diese sind nicht
alt
ein paar Kilometer weiter in mi Bay Swan
sind sie auf Totenkult spezialisiert
hier kann man alles kaufen was den
Lieben im Jenseits Glück und Wohlstand
bringen soll
papierpuppen Papiergeld ein E-Bike ein
Pferd
dieser Ladeninhaber ist auf Kleidung für
Verstorbene spezialisiert und erzählt
uns er habe noch nie so viel verkauft
wie in den vergangenen Wochen
schauen Sie sich unsere Regale an hier
ist fast nichts mehr da in unseren zwei
Lagern gibt es keine totenanzüge mehr
wir haben nicht gedacht dass sich das
Virus so schnell verbreitet viele die
gestorben sind sind 90 Jahre und älter
diese Dame stellt sich als Frau pay vor
sie verkauft Grabgestecke Kunstblumen in
allen möglichen Farben
wir verkaufen gerade drei bis fünfmal so
viel und in ganz China
doch trotz dieser Belege zählt Chinas
Gesundheitsbehörde bislang knapp 82.000
Kobe tote internationale Experten halten
diese Zahl für viel zu gering der
Datenverarbeiter er findet die in London
geht inzwischen von mindestens einer
million-toten aus
wir sind bislang von zwei
ausgegangen jetzt aber nur noch von
einer großen denn das Virus hat sich
schneller als erwartet in die ländlichen
Gebiete ausgebreitet der Höhepunkt ist
aber jetzt erreicht die Zahlen gehen
langsam herunter
auf dem Land müssen die Menschen oft
sehr weit bis zur nächsten Klinik fahren
viele sterben in ihren Häusern sie
werden in keiner Statistik erfasst wie
viele Kurve Tote in China wirklich
beklagt wurden wird wohl nie bekannt
werden
wer in letzter Zeit mal die neuen
Bürobauten rund um den Berliner
Hauptbahnhof etwa erlebt hat hat sich
vielleicht auch gefragt warum die alle
so gleich aussehen und warum niemand
andere Ideen hatte als lauter Fenster
rein die wirken wie Schießscharten
Architektur beeinflusst unser Leben
Architektur kann unser Leben besser
machen und schöner wenn es gute
Architektur ist zu erleben in Kopenhagen
der neuen Welthauptstadt der Architektur
diese Dame ist weltberühmt
ist sie doch das Wahrzeichen der
dänischen Hauptstadt
doch Kopenhagen ist doch für etwas
anderes bekannt seine Architektur
[Musik]
auch diese kopenhagenerin ist
international gefragt die neue Oper ihr
architektonischer Beitrag was Kopenhagen
anders macht ist dass wir erst darüber
gesprochen haben was für ein leben wir
hier gerne haben wollen und erst dann
ging es darum wie es aussehen soll
Müllverbrennungsanlagen werden zu
Skipisten Masten wachsen in den Himmel
in kaum einer anderen Metropole werden
aus Ideen auch wagemutige Projekte und
wo kein Platz ist schafft man welchen
ein Spielplatz über den Dächern
die Architektur in Kopenhagen ist sehr
vielseitig es ist etwas für jeden
Geschmack dabei und das finde ich
fantastisch
es ist der Mix aus historischen Bauten
und kühner moderne die mich begeistert
Kopenhagen Weltarchitektur Hauptstadt
2023 ein Status für drei Jahre verliehen
von der UNESCO den Titel verdankt die
Stadt nicht nur den hübschen Gebäuden
die soziale und nachhaltige Stadtplanung
gab den Ausschlag wir haben wir hoffen
dass die Leute hierher kommen um sich
von der Art und Weise inspirieren lassen
wie wir mit unserem städtischen Raum
umgehen dabei war Kopenhagen nicht immer
der coole Ort als der er heute erscheint
Anfang der 90er so stadtarchitektin
Camilla von dörrs war die City Bankrott
unwirtschaftlich und als Wohnort
unattraktiv heute ist gutes Design Teil
der dänischen DNA hier baut man anders
modern nachhaltig und mit
beeindruckender Optik
[Musik]
in Kopenhagen regiert die Schönheit der
Formen
passend dass die schöne aus
andersensmärchen das Symbol dieser Stadt
ist
und jetzt die Lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 5 14 20 30 38 44 Superzahl 8
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
doch die Wetteraussichten morgen im
Norden stark bewölkt und örtlich etwas
Regen oder Schneeregen anfangs mit
Glättegefahr sonst nach Nebelauflösung
oft freundlich -2 bis plus 7 Grad in der
neuen Woche sehr wechselhaft mit Regen
Schnee und Graupelschauern dazu
stürmischer Westwind Höchstwerte 1 bis 9
Grad
und dann bleiben jetzt noch zwei
TV-Tipps von dir gleich zu das aktuelle
sportstudio und die nächste heute
Express zum 0.25 und ein auf Wiedersehen
von uns allen hier bis morgen
Wiedersehen tschüss
[Musik]